hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play SCP
containment breach version 6.1 I know
everyone has been reminding me but you
know usually I know about these things
ok I'm not gonna get into that anyway
I'm gonna give it a new try there's a
new ending there's like a bullet
taking mechanic where you can take
bullets to the chest and not die there's
a first-aid mechanic there's a new SCP
so I'm gonna find the new ending there's
a new intro sequence to so I'm gonna
find that to really explore this play
again 3 x16 ok scp-173 is a constructed
is constructed from concrete and rebar
with traces of Krylon brand spray-paint
yeah I cannot do this about 1 7 3 you
all know about Billy he's a silly little
[ __ ]
no one likes him no unlike some I think
I think actually scp-173 was the
origination of the SCP you know legend
as a whole all of SCP started with this
one picture that spread about the
internet if you find if you just google
SCP one something you'll find the
original picture that was just like a
picture that was posted on some forum or
some maybe something awful I'm not sure
where it originated but that after that
it all started what done how though this
is indeed different that's in Brighton
here what I get
hmm Class D orientation leaflet on
behalf of the SCP or Foundation and our
staff we welcome you to an exciting one
month's working period in while one of
our top-secret uh-huh got some work for
you ok please step out of the cell
hang on I'm reading here see what was
that did you hear that aren't you
concerned he eats are you deaf or what
shut up who as I said I'm reading will
just terminate you and get the guy from
the next so oh good good
haha Jess follow me we're authorized to
kill any disobedient test subjects so
don't try anything stupid
I'll try something I'll trust something
so hard
okay I'm a following following it's so
nice looking in here so nice look no gas
shooting into my eyeballs this is lovely
uh why you be staring at me like that yo
we are okay in there and follow the
instructions from the intercom and
you'll probably be fine okay thanks for
the vote of confidence
douche McGee I think I'll uh I'll
remember you when you're dead
tinnitus this is familiar hey wait a
minute when did you grow a goatee you is
ugly please enter the fugly okay now
it's familiar hello Class D placeholder
oh there's a place for models whoops
okay
please approach testing bye there seems
to be a problem with the door controls
okay the door is responding to any of
our attempts to close it so please
maintain direct eye contact with scp-173
gonna be dead soon dead I'm dead yet and
now we're back to the old familiar ways
a lot darker than I remember I think
they might have ulcers a darkness just a
bit the running is a little different to
the feels different I don't know but
either way now we're back into the old
familiar pattern look is this ESCP they
added is this one they added I'm not
sure this is 372 he's the little one
that darts out of your vision one of
your eyes I'm not sure if he's n boy
yeah the running is there's like a
running wobble now oh no it feels a bit
better I like it I like it I like the
updates they made it so far so good
how long time it died huh now there's a
box actually go into that thing nope
miss me dick aha there now looks like
the hand is on the other foot now yes I
know yes I don't know one second I know
there's a key card in here somewhere
that I can obtain isn't there hello nice
friggin sight agent agent okay Eric why
ron arad that's not important to me
what is the freaking card oh don't tell
me they change the card location oh no
oh no I'm screwed
I am screwed
what is this why was this why did I hear
Billy just like new zip zooming whoa
what is this I cannot see anything I
cannot see anything
Oh God Oh aah
what that what was that what what
happened what was that place who's down
there I don't know what happened okay
there might be a lot more added than
they mentioned in the changelog cuz hey
I definitely updated the running they
definitely updated on the lighting
engine just a little bit and I don't
know what the hell I just ran into but
I'm going the other way that might have
been Billy I heard him oh wait what ah
there's me Kearney and there's me
navigate air yes alright so that's good
the same thing same thing thing okay I
actually have a car now though yay go me
oh ah Billy get douchenozzle
I'm in a way uh hang on I'm gonna
assemble my running Jew he is much more
mobile
he's like ridiculously more mobile now
not fair okay here we go
HUP why are you ah
oh yeah it's definitely they definitely
pumped up the darkness of whoa did you
see him you seeing them zipping around
there who's that
holy crap balls what the holy holy
Moroni geez oh come on I don't think
this give me clearance and do it do
oh it do let me get my super card close
up this so he can't get me let's barely
get me now and then go through the same
familiar pattern of upgrading the level
to on just fine fine
hunk
what am i oh that oh oh this is the
first aid kit that they were talking
about if I get shot and don't die I can
use that to heal myself yay and stuff
okay got myself a level three I'm gonna
upgrade this all the way to on me and
then I'll upgrade the last one once I go
on da me crew Chuck oh yeah oh yeah and
there are quite a few changes in this I
was waiting I was waiting to start this
backup for big update and I wasn't sure
that this update was gonna be big enough
but I am happy that this update is so
girthy it I can't withstand its girth
okay so there we go and one last time
for the level 5 and then I'll get the
one last time for the Omni and then I'll
be good and I'll be good
oh yes level five indeed okay Omni Omni
Omni Omni Omni I don't know what the
difference is between unlocking
something with an omni or what that what
an omni can unlock as opposed to a level
five I don't know so maybe there's
something at it in the a new ending that
I'll find out and Omni Oh Oh keycard
Omni now I'm gonna change all my other
stuff okay what happens if you put a
first-aid kit in here I'm curious I'm
curious something must have happened
something something a super healbot will
come out come on ah I'm curious I might
just turn it into a pile of ash but I am
curious
ah come on air or I crashed my game okay
you can't do that for that so getting
back in the game
sorry everybody hello everybody my name
is markiplier and well wait a minute
vomit what the hell am i doing okay wait
I I got confused there for a second mark
bot is confused I thought I forgot what
I did was I forgot to restart my I
forgot to restart my fraps after I did
so I accidentally went ahead and got my
keycard Omni and all oldham and gas mask
when I couldn't the the error message
was um there was no fine first take it
so I couldn't upgrade that is scp-682
which I heard that they got a new model
of I don't see Billy I don't know where
Billy was put on the gas mask
what hey hi
the door wasn't even open you weren't
even in that room
oh no oh no I'm gonna be where I was
before I started recording
I'm way over here yeah I accent like I
said I started recording I forgot so I
backtracked so I could start back there
I didn't get very far but I did
encounter though was this an almost duck
and that's when I realized that hey oh
this weird duck which is much nicer than
this Billy
every time you blink he disappears to do
a new place I don't know why I don't
know what for for what reason what he
does
oh that's nice okay so anyway I'm not
gonna backtrack because there wasn't
much stuff anyway I just got to a new
hub I went through the other door and
went through the new Hobbit here so
there was nothing between that I don't
know I don't want to go back there for
multiple reasons
anyway um oh man oh okay so anyway I'm
here what is this what is this what is
this what is this what is this they they
have added a lot more new stuff then
I've previously anticipated and I hear I
hear him dancing around down there and
that's why I do you
I don't you oh god I know there's no way
in hell I'm going down there
screw that screw everything about look
it's so the old man radical Larry okay
I'm not going this way then do that and
screw you Billy what are you doing down
there
I hope there's not something down there
I need cuz I see you I see you who the
king darker down there or something I
don't know I don't know I don't care I
I'm staying with you damn duck hey damn
duck
whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh their new toy odd
Oh can't do it I can't do it I can't do
it I can't do it I can't do it I can't
do it I can't do it I can't do it I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm staying here
in this room with duck I'm done I'm done
in your ducky-wucky
I'm done I'm done I don't know I don't
even know what time it is because my
hope I'm close to five done I'm done I
can't do this anymore
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye the door check
myself here we go what was this blue
super juice up
you're gonna get ready for some baton
action yeah your hands and no no hands
ha ha oh hey oh yes not that way Oh get
out of em all out